remind me what would labor do
specifically to deter people getting on
those boats you know we would do many
things differently to the government
Unfortunately they haven't had a plan
and actually this most recent bill is
just a warmed up version of what they
introduced before it hasn't deterred
it's actually led to for example the
people Smugglers actually receiving more
funds than they did before the first
thing that we would do is we would stop
the situation where there's incredibly
slow processing of people who come over
you know whether it's by boats or other
means only one percent of people who
came over by boats last year have
actually been processed so in fact
Cooper has been Crystal Clear we'd focus
on making sure that we speedily were
processing people there will be people
who have a right to be here obviously
we've always had that tradition as a
country but where people do not have the
right to be here we shouldn't see those
cases going on for months even years in
many cases secondly we would make sure
the National Crime agency actually had
the resources and the powers that it
needs to crack down on the people
Smugglers you know Labor's made many
suggestions to Robert gemrick and the
conservatives about what needs to be
done there you know for example we want
to see the National Crime agency working
with other governments and their
services we want to see proper action
being taken with the French government
for example to be really driving down
what's taking place with those criminal
people Smugglers then the final thing of
course that we would do is have proper
return agreements with other countries
you know again something that the
conservative government promised to
deliver that they haven't delivered
labor would be focused on making sure
that we had those agreements but none of
those concrete legislation is it well
it's concrete measures that would
deliver very rapid change we've seen the
conservatives passing legislation which
hasn't not only made the situation any
better it's actually in some cases some
would argue May the situation even worse
you know we had legislation passed last
year which the conservatives said would
deal with these issues it hasn't we've
actually seen the number of people for
example accommodated in hotels
increasing now that's terrible for
everyone you know it's awful for the
people left in limbo there but it's
terrible also for the taxpayer and this
is really expensive and every expert
analysis of what the conservatives are
setting out now suggest that we'll see
even more people being housed in those
kinds of hotels because of their
approach Labor's got a very different
approach it's a practical one to deal
with these issues we saw the BB
Stockholm that that accommodation boat
arrive on the south coast this week what
would labor do about that would you have
more of those or would you get rid of
them
well we would seek not to have more of
those kinds of facilities because we
would want to make sure that people will
actually process speedily you know if
you look at what's happened over the
last 13 years you've not seen a focus
from government on this issue you've
seen those waiting times the ultimate
amount of time it takes from the moment
someone makes an application to when
it's processed just lengthening and
lengthening under the conservatives you
know that as I said is not good for
anyone labor would make sure that we got
a grip on that that we were actually
properly fast tracking dealing with
cases properly you know we've done that
before actually when labor was in
government when there was an issue we
dealt with it we've not seen that from
the conservatives we've had a lot of hot
air but we've not had delivery
okay
um the election results pretty solid set
of election results for the labor party
uh you all seem pretty happy
536 Council seats up
do you expect not hope expect that you
will form a majority government at the
next election yes I genuinely do on the
basis of these results I think not only
did we see that lead for labor obviously
lengthening but we also saw that labor
was winning and with really big swings
in many of the areas that are
particularly important for us forming
that majority government of course these
elections didn't include Scotland and
actually in Scotland we're moving ahead
as well so yes I do believe that we are
on track to form a majority government
okay you believe that
um the respected Sky News election
analyst Michael Thrasher says no he said
you would fall short 28 seats short of a
majority this is his prediction if we
extrapolate out those figures uh you can
see it there 28 seat short
um
this government has been mired in all
sorts of problems we've had three prime
ministers economically the mass of the
squeeze and income since the second
world war why do you think you didn't do
better than that well actually I think
that Michael Thrasher has been very
clear that certain assumptions fed into
his model you know particularly
assumptions around what like what's
likely to take place in Scotland and
Libra is moving forward very strongly in
Scotland we also didn't see of course
elections in London nor in many of our
really big cities during the set of
Elections so actually to be
extrapolating from the overall picture
in terms of a general election isn't
that helpful the most helpful thing here
is to look at the places where labor was
picking up support because they're
indicative of whether we're going to be
winning in those real swing marginal
seats and in so many of those places you
know Stoke Dover many many places right
up and down the country we saw labor
making games that were really pretty
large gains they show we're on track for
that majority government but a lot of
people said they should have been bigger
and wonder what it is you know that
people are not voting labor for is it
policy is it personality or perhaps your
leader or is it the history of past
labor governments what do you think is
the thing that is putting people off
that perhaps should in your mind be
voting labor well I have to say I didn't
find people being put off you know I
campaigned up and down the country from
Swindon all the way up to Sunderland
during these elections I spoke with you
know hundreds maybe even pushing
thousand people I don't know really very
very many people during the campaign and
before it and what I find overwhelmingly
was that people are feeling that
pressure from the cost of living crisis
every single day they don't have a
government that's taking action to
support them Labor's plans particularly
that plan to plug the windfall tax gaps
so that we could freeze council tax was
very popular on the doorstep so was our
plan of course to get rid of the non-don
tax status and use that money to
massively boost our NHS Workforce so
people could see that labor was setting
out those Solutions we do have many
months of course it appears until the
next general election I wish it was
going to come sooner because I think our
country needs change right now but we do
have those months to come and Libra is
going to continue you to set out those
really practical Solutions with a
mission-led government and again when I
talked about that long-term Focus from
labor people were really attracted to
that compared to the sticking plaster
politics under the conservatives that
we've had for so long you said obviously
you expect that you will form a majority
government but kierstama seems to be
wavering slightly about whether or not
there would be a Coalition in July last
year he said that he is ruling out any
Arrangement any kind of Coalition with
anyone yesterday our political editor
Beth Rigby interviewed him uh about a
hypothetical deal with the s p
completely ruled it out so we asked
about a hypothetical deal with the lib
Dems he didn't rule out let's have a
listen to what he said
so you are ruling out a deal with the s
p on any terms but you're not ruling out
a deal with the libderms well as you
know with the asmp it's a fundamental
difference I do not believe in the
breakup and separation of the United
Kingdom just to be clear you're ruling
out any sort of arrangement with the s p
and you are not doing that with the
liberal Democrats unclear I'm pressing
on I want a labor majority government
workable majority
we also not seven times and he only
wouldn't answer so a deal with the lib
Dems is possible isn't it if you vote
labor well actually what Kier said was
absolutely correct that he's aiming for
a majority government and you know it's
not Party leaders but that's why people
decide the outcome of this but I think
the question is what the electorate
wants and it's going to be there for
years is would would there potentially
be a coalition with a live Denver people
are going to vote labor they need to
know whether they're voting labor or the
weather the voting labor with the
possibility of a labor lib Dem Coalition
but what they can know very clearly is
that labor is determined not to have a
coalition government instead to have a
majority labor governments how people
vote at the end of the day in The Ballot
Box quite rightly it's the secret ballot
they will vote how they want to vote I'm
confident that as people see what Libra
is setting out for our country that
change so finally we can have a Britain
that works for working people when they
see that that they will support that
majority labor government if it's
if it isn't a majority labor government
you're not ruling out that it could be a
coalition with the lib Dems you're not
ruining it out
what I would say is you know it's for
other parties to be clear if we have
that labor government but it's our labor
government yeah but if I can just finish
we have a labor government that's
setting out those plans for example to
scrap the non-dom tax exemption use that
money to boost our NHS Workforce if we
find other parties want to vote against
that well the responsibility for it will
be on their shoulders not on Labor's
shoulders because we're setting out that
perspectives for a change okay so he
wouldn't rule out and you're not ruling
it out either and finally um in in prime
minister's questions today the Prime
Minister called kirstarma uh he's
already called him Mr flip-flop Mr
Softee call them Mr flaky today there
have been a lot of u-turns we've seen
tuition fees U-turn um labor now not
scrapping those re-national of the
utilities not so much there vowing to
stand with the trade unions barring
cabinet members from from joining picket
lines why should voters trust what is
written in Labor's Manifesto for this
next election when you've u-turned on
all of these things that were in your
last
because every election is a new election
when a political party will present a
Manifesto based on the circumstances
well every party always draws up a new
Manifesto I think people would be pretty
surprised if any party just photocopied
what had been there before these
circumstances are different and actually
care has been really open and clear he's
not going to have a kind of last minutes
back of a packet frankly approach
that we've seen far too often with
policy announcements just driven by
politics we've had enough of that
sticking plaster start from the
conservatives he set out those long-term
missions they're unashamedly long time
he's clear it's going to be difficult
for us to achieve for example that goal
of having the highest sustained growth
in the G7 but nonetheless he's
determined that we as a country will get
there and he's setting out the Practical
measures to get there he's not saying
that it's going to be easy but he's been
very open about that fact this is going
to be a collective effort across our
country I think that's a really
different style of politics actually
that's coming from here it's one that's
respectful of people and that indicates
he's going to govern in partnership with
business with trade unions with local
government as well in the interests of
our country again a big contrast I'm
afraid with what we've had recently and
lizards thank you very much